[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
you to hear what we have to say because
they're cowards they can't engage in the
argument
all they could try to do is shut us down
and silence us but it's not going to
work we're still here
we're not going anywhere
we're still here
so what is the cause that we are here
for it's very simple we are here to
fulfill one of our most fundamental
obligations As Americans as adults as
human beings and that is to protect our
children
that is why we're here
you're giving them an opportunity to be
special and to get special treatment
without any special act they haven't
done anything that warrants that
unique Behavior yeah I think that's a
really important point I think I think
that's that's actually so much of this
that and and people don't notice it but
a lot of this is uh is just it's just
standard narcissism yes especially you
listen to these you know why is this so
common among celebrities now all the
celebrities have have uh trans kids and
they're coming out as non-binary and
whatever else and then you listen to
like Demi Lovato whoever and you listen
to them explain why they're they them
it's always well I just uh I I just I
don't identify with these labels I'm
beyond that I'm above that it's like
these labels were good enough for
billions of humans before you but it's
not good enough for you that you can't
find yourself there but but all these
other billions of human beings it was
fine they had no problem but you're so
special that we need to change the rules
of the English language for you
specifically it's it's incredibly
egotistical
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
just like the four-year-old can't answer
what is a girl
well this is one of the problems with
this left-wing gender ideology is that
no one who espouses it
can even tell you what these words means
like what is a woman can you tell me
what a woman is no I can't
because it's not for me to say I
Womanhood looks different for everybody
what do you what do you define a woman
as an adult human female and what does a
female mean
uh someone with with female reproductive
organs okay someone who's you know
here's the thing when you're when you're
a female it goes right down to your
bones your DNA so that's why if someone
dies okay we could dig up their bones
100 years from now we have no idea what
they believed in their head but we can
tell what sex they were because it's in
it's down in it's it's ingrained in
every fiber of their being interesting
so I'm trying to understand your
definition is that a woman is someone
who is female you said right correct
there's a biological female so what
happens if we have maybe someone who is
female identifies as a woman right you
know cisgender woman right as you
explain as you just explained maybe
doesn't have the ability to reproduce
well maybe doesn't have those organs
that you're talking about that are
reproductive organs I have answered the
question
you stood up here and said trans women
are women yes tell me what you mean what
is a Womanhood is something that just as
Ethan explained I cannot Define because
I am not myself so what did you mean
when you said trans women are women if
you don't know what it means right so
here's the thing so I do not Define what
a woman is because I do not identify as
a woman Womanhood is something that is
an umbrella term it includes people that
describes what
people who identify as a woman identify
as what as a woman what is that was to
each their own
[Music]
can a man become a woman
I'm not a woman so I I can't really
answer that women only know what women
are are you a cat no can you tell me
what a cat is
you want to tell us what a woman is
I'm a biological woman that medically
transitioned to appear like a male I
will never
be a man and so they go on the internet
and they're told that all their problems
will be solved if they become a man so
you worry that there there could be a
sort of social contagion element of this
a teeny tiny bit maybe it got me at 42.
your child doesn't have a chance the
interview is over let's turn off the
cameras excuse me another fair I just
wanted to know what is a woman and
you're not going to find out based on
what I'm saying would you ever want to
move to America that's what they say
enough never
foreign
[Music]